love is our highest value what we all
crave and what we believe makes us
fundamentally human but it's also the
source of considerable anxiety chiefly
we worry whether we're entirely normal
because it frequently feels as if we're
not experiencing love the way we should
be society is subtly highly prescriptive
in this regard it suggests that to be a
decent person we should all be within
sexual relationships and furthermore
that within these we should love in a
very particular way we should be
constantly thrilled by our partners
presence we should long to see them
after every absence we should crave to
hold them in our arms to kiss and be
kissed by them and most of all want to
have sex with them every day also in
other words we should follow the script
of romantic ecstasy throughout our lives
this is beautiful in theory and hugely
punitive in practice if we're going to
define love like this and PEG the idea
of normality accordingly then most of us
will have to admit to ourselves
perhaps with considerable embarrassment
that we don't know much about love and
therefore don't qualify as decent sane
or normal people we've created a cult of
love radically out of line with most of
our real experiences of relationships
this is where the ancient Greeks can
help they realized early on that there
are many kinds of love each with their
respective virtues and seasons and that
a good society requires us to append a
correct vocabulary to these different
states of the heart lending each one
legitimacy in the process
the Greeks anointed the powerful
physical feelings we often experience at
the start of a relationship with the
word eros but they knew that love is not
necessarily over when the sexual
intensity wanes as it almost always does
after a year or so in a relationship our
feelings can then evolve into another
sort of love they captured with the word
philia normally translated as
ship though the Greek word is far warmer
more loyal and more touching than its
English counterpart one might be willing
to die for philia aristotle recommended
that we outgrow eros in youth and then
base our relationships especially our
marriages on a philosophy of philia the
word adds an important nuance to our
understanding of a viable union it
allows us to see that we may still love
even when we're in a phase that our own
more one-sided vocabulary fails to value
the Greeks had a third word for love
agape this can best be translated as a
charitable love it's what we might feel
towards someone who's behaved rather
badly or come to grief through floors of
character but for whom we still feel
compassion it's what a god might feel
for his or her people or what an
audience might feel for a tragic
character in a play it's the kind of
love that we experience in relation to
someone's weakness rather than their
strength it reminds us that love isn't
just about admiration for virtues it's
also about sympathy and generosity
towards what is weak and imperfect in us
having these three words to hand eros
philia and agape powerfully extends our
sense of what love really is the ancient
Greeks were wise in dividing the
blinding monolith of love into its
constituent parts under their tutelage
we can see that we probably have far
more love in our lives than our current
vocabulary knows how to recognize did
you know that the school of life is
actually a place ten places in fact
campuses all over the world from
Melbourne to London
Taipei to Istanbul with classes and
books and lots more
please click on the link below to
explore more